they became like these things and you
saw them enough in movies where you
thought people actually did it like
nobody ever took a chick right at her
place and just [__] cleared off a
table breaking [__] and put her on and
she didn't get mad like what the [__]
are you doing you're breaking all my you
ever remember that that was like the
move in the 80s you grab some chick she
Str you HTS flying oh yeah yeah very
rapy yeah who's going to clean this very
rapy it was very grabb and [__] it's a
trump error I I remember when I had
friends in high school go dude she blew
me with an ice cube in her mouth and I
was like was it awful was terrible I had
a woman do that one time like what the
[__] are you do the stupid the whole
point of a [__] is to not have cold
like what like what else you going to do
no that was the original ice
bath